FALSE IMPRESSION THAT YOU
WOULD ACTUALLY HEAR FROM ROB
GRONKOWSKI. WE DON'T HAVE THE
SOUND. I GUESS I CAN READ THE
YOU LIAR. YOU LIKE A LIAR TO
READ IT LIKE, I'M ROB
GRONKOWSKI. OKAY, LET ME HEAR
YOUR ROB GRONKOWSKI, BOYS.
JULES WAS AN UNBELIEVABLE
PLAYER, AND HE LITERALLY
GIVES IT HIS ALL FOR HIS
TEAMMATES. I JUST WISH THE
BEST FOR JULIAN TO HEAL UP.
OBVIOUSLY, IN HIS LOOK, I
CAN'T DO IT. THAT'S
MMM, ANY GOOD IS GOOD. I
LIKED IT FOREVER AND I'M WITH
YOU. I LIKE THAT. SO SO WHAT
HE SAYS IS I'M HOPING HE
HEALS UP. I WANT THE BEST FOR
MY BEEN IN THAT SITUATION
BEFORE I BELIEVE WHO BELIEVE
IF JULIAN TRULY HEELS UP,
WHATEVER IS HURTING ON HIM
AND HE FULLY HEALS AND FEELS
GOOD. I THINK HE'LL BE BACK.
I DON'T SEE WHY HE WOULDN'T
BE BACK EVENTUALLY THE
FACTION THE OTHER MAYBE A
YEAR OR TWO AWAY. REMEMBER
REMEMBER WHEN WHEN WHAT WAS
THAT TWO YEARS AGO WE
CAST HIM?
TERMINATOR FOOD OF THE
TERMINATOR, RIGHT? AND I
ACTUALLY COUNTED THE NUMBER
OF LINES THAT ARNOLD
SCHWARZENEGGER HAD IN THE
ORIGINAL. YES. AND WE
CONCLUDED THAT GRONK COULD
PULL IT OFF, RIGHT? IT WAS 17.
I THINK I'LL BE BACK IN 69
MINUTES.
YOU'RE ON A ROLL TODAY. I
LOVE IT. WELL THE ANYWAY.
ANYWAY ANYWAY PAY NO
ATTENTION TO THAT MAN BEHIND
THE CURTAIN DESPITE
EVERYTHING JULIAN EDELMAN
SAYS, ONE OF HIS FORMER
BACK. WELL, I MEAN YOU KNOW
AGAIN I'M NOT GOING TO BUY
IT RIGHT NOW, JUST FROM THE
THINGS, I DO KNOW AND THE
STATUS OF JULIAN EDELMAN HIS
BODY, LIKE, IT DOESN'T SOUND
LIKE THIS IS SOMETHING WHERE
IT'S LIKE A ROUND THE CORNER,
AND HE MIGHT HEAL UP. AND I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S GOING TO
BE SPECULATION ABOUT THIS ALL
YEAR LONG BECAUSE A BRADY AND
GRONK AND EVERYTHING LIKE
THAT. YOU KNOW. BUT MAN,
THESE ARE TWO PEAS IN A POD.
IT'S EVEN THOUGH THERE ARE
TWO DIFFERENT BODIES AND KIND
OF AN APPROACH TO LIFE. THERE
A COMMON LIKE,
SKI EDELMAN, PSYCHO -
OBSESSIVENESS ABOUT FOOTBALL,
AND BEING ALL IN AND PLAYING
MATTER WHAT. AND THAT'S WHAT
THE BOND WOULD THAT PATRIOTS
TEAM IS AND WAS, THEY HAD SO
MANY OF THOSE GUYS. THAT'S
WHERE THE GREAT SCOUTING OF
NEW ENGLAND AND BILL.
BELICHICK CAME INTO CAME IN
HANDY. THEY BUILT GUYS THAT
YOU KNOW, WEREN'T HOSTAGES
VOLUNTEERS AS THEY SAY, LOVE
THE GAME. ALWAYS WANTED TO BE
THERE. OH WHAT I HAVE A BAD
BADLY HURT ANKLE. SO WHAT
I'LL TRY TO PLAY THIS WEEK,
HELL WITH IT. SO THAT'S
CAN'T REALLY BELIEVE THAT
JULIAN'S GOT GONNA WALK AWAY
HERE DURING THE DRAFT WITH ON
THAT UNFOLDED DURING THE
DRAFT COVERAGE ITSELF. I
STILL UNDERSTAND WHY THEY DO
THAT DURING THE DRAFT. WHY
NOT DO IT MONDAY TUESDAY,
WEDNESDAY BEFORE THE DRAFT
BECAUSE WHO'S REALLY
WATCHING THE ONLINE DRAFT
WITH ON WHILE THE DRAFT IS ON.
ANYWAY, THAT'S JUST MY OWN
SHARIA PROGRAMMING  MIKE,
SUGGESTION FOR THE FOLKS AT
NFL MEDIA, BRADY POSSIBLY
AFTER HAVING A BELT OR TWO
OF AVOCADO, TEQUILA SAID, WE
KNOW JULIAN DIDN'T RETIRE.
LET'S BE HONEST. HE'S JUST
TO TELL BILL, HE WANTS TO
COME TO TAMPA. I LOVE THAT. I
DIDN'T SEE THAT. THAT WAS,
THAT WAS THE JOKE FROM. TOP
KNOW YOU DIDN'T WORK THAT.
WELL, YOU DID WORK THAT
FRIDAY AND YOU STILL DIDN'T
SEE IT. BUT ANYWAY THAT WAS
THE JOKE FROM TOM BRADY AND
AND JULIAN EDELMAN PLAYED
ALONG WITH IT BUT EVENTUALLY
HADN'T MADE IT CLEAR. HE'S
DONE. AND LOOK HE CAN'T MOVE
FOXBORO FOREVER MERCHANDISE
IF YOU LEAVE THE DOOR CRACKED
BACK, RIGHT? SO IT'S IN HIS
BUSINESS INTERESTS, JULIAN,
EDELMAN.COM, FOXBOROUGH
FOREVER, REGISTERED TRADEMARK.
I HAVE A FEELING NOT QUITE
SELLING AS BRISKLY AS HE
WOULD HAVE THOUGHT, BUT ONCE
YOU SELL ALL YOUR FOXBOROUGH
FOREVER GEAR, THEN YOU CAN,
THEN YOU CAN BE TAMPA, BAY
KNOW, I DON'T KNOW, I DON'T,
IS ONE WHERE I DON'T GET OR
SEE THIS HAPPENING. I DON'T
EITHER, BUT I, BUT WE CAN'T.
YOU'RE RIGHT. GRONKOWSKI
SAYING IT OVER AND OVER. NO,
GET UP, I MEAN, HE'S NOT BUT
BUT YOU'RE RIGHT YOU KNOW
EDELMAN I THINK THIS IS THIS
AN ISSUE THAT HE HAD BEEN
DEALING WITH THE LAST TWO
IN NEW ENGLAND, HE LIMPED TO
THE FINISH LINE AND MADE THAT
SEASON HAPPEN AND IT WAS A
LOT OF WORK. I THINK TO GET
READY FOR THE YEAR LAST YEAR
AND OF COURSE IT FINALLY.
JUST FELL APART TO WHERE HE
FEELS LIKE HE CAN'T DO IT
ANYMORE SO WE'LL SEE. I MEAN,
BE AWESOME IF IT CAME
NOVEMBER AND ALL THE SUDDEN
HE'S SIGNING WITH WITH TAMPA
BAY. AND WE GOT SOMETHING TO
TALK ABOUT LIKE THAT, I'D
WE SPENT ALL OF THE 2019
ROB GRONKOWSKI WAS GOING TO
RETURN TO THE PATRIOTS AND
THERE WAS A SPECIFIC DEADLINE.
IF YOU'RE ON THE RESERVE
RETIRED LIST WHERE YOU HAVE
TO GET OFF OF IT ONCE AND FOR
ALL AND COME BACK WITHOUT A
WOMAN WHO WAS CUT BY THE
PATRIOTS, THERE'S NO POINT IN
LATE NOVEMBER, EARLY DECEMBER,
HE CONSIGNED WITH ANYONE
ANYTIME UP TO AND INCLUDING
SUPER BOWL WEEK, HE CAN SIGN
WITH A TEAM. SO HE'S A FREE
IT'S THIS YEAR, WHETHER IT'S
AN EXTRA, WHETHER IT'S THE
YEAR AFTER. IT'S SOMETHING,
WE JUST HAVE TO KEEP AN EYE
ON AND WE'VE SEEN IT BEFORE,
WILL SAY WITH 100% CERTAINTY
THAT SOMETHING IS GOING TO
HAPPEN AND THEN THE EXACT
OPPOSITE EVENTUALLY HAPPENS.
AND WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO?
OH, YOU LIED OR OU IT. WE
JUST GO WITH IT WHEN IT T HAPP
S.HA WPPE ENHAS.VE W TE O HAVEEN
T
O WHKEENEP I A